bin der
Abholservice wir sind da drüben im
reddesen wir fangen unsere Interviews
immer mit einer offenen Frage an weil
wir einfach mal gucken wollen wohin geht
die Reise und deshalb lautet die
meistens wie ist die Lage
großartig die Lage ist besser könnte es
eigentlich gar nicht sein wir sind
gerade mit einer neuen Platte unterwegs
die heißt die neuen Männer wir sind sehr
stolz drauf wir gehen bald auf Tour also
die prinzenmaschine läuft auf Hochtouren
und wir sind glücklich und die Lage
könnte eigentlich nicht besser sein also
wir haben sogar einen extrem charmanten
und wohlrieenden Interviewpartner noch
guck wir
mal das hat jetzt wenn ich richtig
informiert bin vier Jahre gedauert
wieder bis zu einem richtigen
Studioalbum ja warum
weil wir lange nach einem Produzenten
gesucht haben und wir haben einen
Produzenten gefunden in Personen von mus
einem eigentlich DJ und sind da sehr
froh und glücklich drüber ist das denn
so schwierig in Produzenten zu finden
mit dem man zurecht kommt da muss man ja
wahrscheinlich eine Wellenlänge haben
dass das
funktioniert das sagt Jens jetzt z.B
Wellenlänge muss man auf jeden Fall
haben und muss vor allem gegenseitigen
Respekt haben das ist wichtig und für
uns als demokratische Haufen war im
Studio dass einer im Endeffekt bei
offenen Fragen sagt zack so wird's
gemacht sonst würden wir es
wahrscheinlich immer noch produzieren
ja wie sieht das aus mit der Wellenlänge
finden das S
Jens Tobias was ja
Wellenlänge na auf Augen muss man sich
mit ihm bewegen das ist schon klar und
er muss das mögen was wir machen er muss
uns respektieren sind es gibt ja
erstaunlicherweise nicht nur prinzenfans
auf der Welt und nicht nur Leute die die
uns toll finden und Musti ist aber einer
ist erstmal Musikfan und Musti kann sich
für alles begeistern was er hört da
findet erstmal alles toll und das hat
gut gepasst was genau es ist auch
wichtig von Produzenten dass er wirklich
selbstbewusst genug ist dem Künstler
doch das ein oder andere auszureden oder
ih auf jeden Fall zu korrigieren und das
brauchen wir auch zumal wir auch zwei
Liedsänger haben andere haben nur ein
und da geht's das ein od andere auch zu
klären und
irgendwie dass die Platte am Ende rund
ist dieses auf Augenhöhe begegnen ist
das ein Problem in der Plattenindustrie
da jemanden zu finden es hat glaube ich
was mit äh mit der plattenustrie gar
nichts zu tun also es gibt viele Leute
die da unterwegs sind und die nicht
unbedingt auf unsere Wellenlänge surfen
aber wie gesagt so jemand wie Musti es
geht wirklich hauptsächlich darum
jemanden zu finden der einen eben
wirklich auch kritisieren kann und nicht
nur der das kann sondern von dem man die
Kritik auch annimmt weil wir natürlich
alle selbst äh von uns so
egomanisch überzeugt sind dass wir alle
uns selbst nicht gegenseitig aber jeder
sich selbst doch durchaus für den
Nobelpreis vorschlagen würde und dann
muss eben erstmal jemand kommen der dann
sagt so Nobelpreis verdächtig ist deine
Kunst gegenseitig auf gar keinen Fall
wir redet nicht miteinander oder wir bei
Interviews reden wir miteinander ne also
doch auf jeden Fall also nein wir kennen
uns ja nur schon wirklich sehr lange
also wir sind ein Haufen seit wir seit
wir 10 Jahre alt sind auß Jens der er
der neue den kennen wir erst seit 18
Jahren 20 Jahren 22 Jahren ja ich fuch
mich noch ein ja das heißt für den
Produzenten heißt einer gegen alle nee
jeder gegen jeden jeder gegen jeden
dasen wie wie ich kann mir das sehr
schwer vorstellen weil ich gibt dir ich
sag mal schon Einzelkünstler können ja
egomanisch sein aber wenn man dann fünf
hat die eine eigene Meinung haben was
macht dann der Produzent also der
Produzent war auch nicht allein hat so
sagen auch le g genau Verstärkung also
im Grunde war ein Produzenten Team so
eine Art Patchwork Arbeit und Musti hat
sich eigentlich wirklich um die um die
Kern Dinger gekümmert und hat auch ein
Kopf frei dann einfach so manchmal bei
dem ein und anderen von draußen zu
gucken sozusagen und und die die
Kleinarbeit des produzentenums sozusagen
seinen zuarbeitern zu überlassen also
das hat auch sehr gut funktioniert weil
man dann manchmal auch ein objektiveren
Blick hat bei dem Titel bei dem Titel B
cool speak Deutsch da hatte ich zunächst
da mein Gott die Melodie das passt das
ist doch sehr gassenhaurig das kann ich
mir auch bei Florian Silbereisen
vorstellen frag ihn mal ja der wird doch
ja sagen oder nicht also wen wie man da
alles sieht da tritt ja auch der tritt
ja auch der tritt ja im
das heißt winterfest der Volksmusik mit
bin ich ziemlich überzeugt ach ja die
Nummer ist einfach wir haben lange an
dem Arrangement gebastelt al das gab da
verschiedene Möglichkeiten da so gruvig
so hiphopmäßig ranzugehen od so
countrymäßig und irgendwann hat dann der
Jan von der Thorn also einer aus dem mus
Team gesagt nee wir machen da so eine so
eine partynummer draus und das hat sich
dann das hat auch am besten gepasst zu
dem Lied also wir haben an der Nummer
wirklich ziemlich lange rumgefallt am
Arrangement gibt's dann Diskussionen
über sowas weil das ist ja eine ganz
andere musikalische Richtung als alle
anderen Titel ja da gibt's schon
Diskussion also es war auch
ja das ging also weil ich se eigentlich
ganz wollte nicht zu floran Silbereisen
nee definitiv ne echt nicht würdet i
nicht machen würden wir glaube ich nicht
hingehen ich glaube muss man schon
wissen man muss eben wirklich gucken
also es gab wegen des Liedes be cool
speak Deutsch habe ich irgendwann mal
Hans Martin Buff der da die ganze Platte
auch gemischt hat der im Studio wirklich
eigentlich technisch auch den Hut auf
hat ich habe ihn gefragt
ob er garantieren kann dass dieses Lied
am Ende nicht peinlich wird wo er wie
aus der Pistole geschossen antwortete
nein kann ich nicht für garantieren ich
glaube das Lied ist jetzt am Ende nicht
peinlich geworden und deswegen bin ich
da
doch man kann dahinterstehen was man da
gemacht hat und du kannst natürlich
überlegen ob du jetzt irgendwas ein
bisschen gruvi anders machst od was weiß
ich was aber gerade dieses Ding B cool
speak Deutsch das mit Blasmusik aufhören
zu lassen das war glaube ich dann
konsequent absolut ja ja also ihr seid
jetzt seid
m wie viel Jahren genau zusammen war se
die Prinzen seit seit 91 aber vorher war
wart ihr schon die Herzbuben glaube ich
aber nicht die Wildecker sondern ja wir
waren vor allem vorher wie gesagt in den
kören und wir kennen uns also Tobias
nicht wir haben jetzt kürzlich mal F
dass wir uns seit
mittlerweile so 73 kennen also 35 Jahre
obwohl wir jünger sind kennen wir uns
schon seit 35 Jahren eine gewisse Logik
und schmidti kennen wir seit 76 und
Wolfgang seit 77 kennen wir uns mit
Wolfgang bin ich seit nur so 76 in einer
Klasse ja das ist schon irgendwie eine
sehr lange Zeit klasse war diese
chorzeit ein gutes Training dafür um
miteinander in so einer Gruppe
auszukommen das auch natürlich war das
im Chor also das für das Zusammenleben
auch jetzt innerhalb der Band extrem
wichtig weil natürlich lernt man schon
im Kindesalter mit Leuten umzugehen auch
wenn so mal keine Ahnung
z.B also wenn jetzt mal einer austickt
wie wir das jetzt gerade gesehen haben
und dann bleibt man eben ganz ruhig wie
man das jetzt auch gesehen hat und und
das lernt man dort eigentlich auch
diesen Umgang halt mit mit si du ich
liebe dich so
komm doch
mal so und und ich denke mal dass das
auch ein großes pluspünktchen ist für
uns dass wir so lange zusammen sind
nicht W wir haben unser Karriere viele
Bands kommen und gehen sehen die das
Glück nicht hatten wir haben sogar
Plattenfirmen komm auch Plattenfirmen
genau was ist da das Training was ist
das eine besondere Atmosphäre bei weil
ich meine es gibt ja auch Schulen in
denen sich die Schüler nicht besonders
gut verstehen
ist das hat das mit dem ch zu tun das
die Disziplin einfach braucht um äh ich
sag mal ein großes Werk aufzuführen es
geht hier in dem Fall nicht nur um
Schulen sondern wir haben ja also 24
Stunden zusammengelebt und das ist ja
genau und das ist halt der Knackpunkt
also dass man sozusagen man konnte nicht
abhauen man konnte nicht weg man konnte
sich einem Problem nicht entziehen
sozusagen man musste sich der Sache
stellen und man hat dann ganz schnell
gemerkt wie wie das funktioniert z ein
Problem ganz schnell zu klären ohne dass
es weh tut man muss natürlich auch dazu
sagen dass gerade Tobias und ich dass
wir damals auch schon äh im tomaner Chor
Rebellen waren dass wir die bunten Vögel
waren D die waren natürlich die und also
ich kann sogar auch mit Fug und Recht
von mir behaupten dass ich kurz vorher
noch rausgeflogen bin was natürlich sich
in einem Lebenslauf immer sehr gut macht
dass man das danach so sagen kann aber
na klar anpassen ist immer irgendwie
eine schwierige Sache und wir haben es
zwar theoretisch gelernt aber praktisch
noch nicht so richtig verinnerlicht
glaube ich ja aber einerseits seit
offensichttig Rebellen aber andererseits
zusammen funktioniert zusammen wir ja
aber nach außen hin also was wir sagen
was wir singen da sagt uns keiner was
das machen wir schon so wie wir das für
richtig hab außer Musti vielleicht
natürlich aber jetzt inhaltlich meine
ich jetzt wenn wenn es um Texte geht
wenn es um irgendwelche Meinungen geht
die man vor sich herträgt und ungefragt
äußert da lassen wir uns nichts sagen ja
außerdem ist ja mus du hast do keine
ahnungem ist ja ist ja Musti das könn
rausschneiden ich sage was Schneid
einfach aus ich will ich will ich will
einfach sagen und der ist in dem Moment
auch Teil des Großen und Ganzen da ist
dann ein einer von uns und dann darf uns
natürlich was sagen D machen wir
gemeinsam ein Ding der hat aber auch
keine Ahnung der hat auch keine Ahnung
also im Prinzip ist so das meintet ihr
jetzt mit Augen die Sache ist es gibt im
Prinzip BL in der Ahnung hat und das ist
der sitzt hier vor mir das ist
Henry also okay gut okay ich habe
verstanden ja das war doch mal
interessant mit diesen fünf ahnungslosen
kommt
aus vier ahnungslosen
dem der Ahnung ne ne das ist Dresden das
wäre Dresen wir kommen aus ach so das
ist der ahnungslose andersrum ein
ahnungslos also wenn einer wirklich
keine Ahnung hat dann Jens ich genau
Teil ahnungslosen hieß damals
so es man sagt ja auch die ARD oder so
heißt außer Raum Dresden das heißt also
man empfängt überall außer dort im Tal
der Ahnungslosen halt dort bin ich groß
geworden aber inzwischen auch mit ARD ja
ich gucke jeden Tag irgendwie ad bin
immer noch begeistert Westfernsehen und
so drehe ich völlig durch Bund superel
dan